who would win in a fight between Nathan
Drake and the Steve from minecraft this
is versus the game Smosh showed that
pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot burn issues against
each other this week PlayStation 4 vs.
Xbox one in the Battle of the better
exclusives fighting for PlayStation is
Oscar Deus who moved from Bristol to
London in 2016 and only just brought his
xbox one over on the flipside he does
like to pretend he's James Bond with
PlayStation peripherals
[Music]
and making the case for Microsoft
console is the Xbox one ex owning Xbox
Live serving Major Nelson fan girl Lucy
who even has a custom Xbox one
controller styled after diva from
overwatch each are going to argue their
corner for their console over the course
of three randomly picked topics with the
overall winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewers last week Oscar Diaz
and Rainbow six siege won with 72% of
the votes
we're going to be throwing up a
clickable poll right here on YouTube
or if you're watching over on
gamespot.com let us know who you think
has won the debate in the comment
section below
but before we get into it if you're
wondering why spider-man and Spyro
aren't featured more heavily in the
arguments it's because this episode was
shot before both games were confirmed to
be launching in 2018 and our resident
clairvoyant was on holiday during the
shoot so we weren't 100% confident
they'd be out on time for that other way
let's get into it
[Music]
hello hello Lucy that's like a very
impractical mode well I don't know what
you're talking about it sir mm-hmm
really a convenient mug that's got
related to stop things coming out yeah I
don't need a safety mark I'm glad you've
got a nice pink controller there thank
you like Karl Rove Xbox well the green
is no I custom-designed that after my
favorite dude stiva I'm gonna pick the
first topic races Xbox is clearly the
best place for racing fans because
within one series you have a series of
games for the hardcore for the petrol
heads SATs quarter then you also have
what's a horizon which is for me for
like the casual fans it's more arcadey
it has this through line of you know
it's like a music festival man you go
into Australia and we got this bangin
tunes and you can just sort of race
against your mates you can also play
with your friends even when they're not
online a busy foot you drive at our
thing I mean unless base it they're not
gonna be online because his xbox and all
of those experiences that you've just
mentioned their PlayStation has as well
I mean for the casual fan I mean I would
probably cast myself as a more casual
end of the spectrum in terms of racers
I really enjoyed drive club and for the
people who weren't sure about whether
they were going to enjoy that there was
also the PS Plus edition as well but
then like you say with Forza you've got
the game that really originally
perfected the hardcore racer in Gran
Turismo and Gran Turismo sport is now on
ps4 which was I mean yes yes it was I
mean as all Gran Turismo games have been
for years and it really nailed the
hardcore aspect of races and if you're
someone who really gets excited about
the nuts and bolts literally of cars
then you can play Gran Turismo sport so
I think clearly ps4 wins this one no I
wouldn't say that they did because Forte
is such an ingrained part of car culture
now and like a bunch of my friends where
petrol heads will always choose Forza
because of that because of how realistic
they feel and also when they announce
for two
vii with the Xbox 1x and they had made
all of those graphical updates
it's literally like every aspect of
realism they can get on those games they
go for that is my problem with fours
notice that there's been so many of them
that I'm just I'm the thing it simply
but there hasn't been a drop in quality
in fact they just get better but is
there any meaningful improvement each
time because they don't say maybe every
year so you cannot use this as an
argument because you essentially buy the
same game every year hang on a minute
since when was FIFA a racing game no no
no that's your argument though that your
argument is there are too many forces
and they come out every year you spend
all of your time playing fifa and PES
which operate on a very similar model
whereas the thought said they do one
year cat like Arkady one year simulation
I actually spend all my time playing
driveclub and run through some of sport
lucy i'll depreciates have you got that
right i'm friends of the on PSN 8 100
knows 2018 clearly PlayStation 4 is
gonna have a better 2018 and it's
already having a better 2018 the year
kicked off in a excellent fashion with
Shadow of the Colossus for all the weeds
out there you got yak as a 6 I'll be
honest I'll be honest I'm not a yak as a
fan but those people do love it and fair
enough haha you got detroit become human
which i mean heavy rain was a really
genuinely great bit of storytelling and
i mean that no no genuine like I've
played some of Detroit and I think I
could get into it but heavy rain
constantly being lauded is this
incredible piece of storytelling you've
got a Spider Man for the comic book fans
out there of which I am one that
open-world looks really incredible and
like insomniac have proven in the past
that they can make amazing games and
spider-man like sunset overdrive on the
Xbox and then to top it all off you've
got God of War mm-hmm is very soon and
like that I've never actually been
interested in God of War before but this
god of war has got me really interested
it looks the combat looks so satisfying
and that's something that I wasn't
really clicking with in previous God of
War games but this one they've clearly
taken cues from the Last of Us which is
one of my favorite games of all time and
that's got me really interested and
therefore
I think this war is the best place to
play in 2018 all right Andrew house it's
the best place to play so you see why
this is like I don't want to say that
all those games have [ __ ] go over luck
cuz they're not they're great but the
thing is Xbox also has a very good run
on 2018 so we haven't even had a three
yet so we don't even know if they're
gonna announce stuff and release it
pretty well coming into 2018
you have things like CU thieves which we
played and it's a ton of fun and it's so
refreshing for a multiplayer game is you
know not only a pirate games few and far
between these days but actually getting
together as a crew and it's a great
return inform return to form for rare
sure might be lacking content but it's a
hell of a lot of fun it's like this game
where you create your own stories so now
that you have games like crackdown 3
with Terry Crews that's finally coming
out it you have Stape decay to like
survival survival horror shooter II game
you have ashen which like you were
saying that shadow of the colossus ashen
basically looks and feels to me like
Dark Souls meets eco meets Shadow of the
Colossus you've got black desert online
which is an MMO like MMOs on console
that is cool man it's like this whole
subsection this whole genre of games
that I've so rarely been on console but
for my final fantasy xiv and it's just
this wide breadth of games from all
different angles MMO platformer battle
royale that's what Xbox is giving this
year they're giving tons of different
types of games for different people I
mean take those three genres that you
mentioned there was it MMO platformer
Battle Royale
that's where we al pub G yeah great
that's yeah they're crackin well done
that was last year for a start but I
mean when pub G is dead everyone's
playing for tonight now and that's
that's across all platforms so you can't
you can't stand on that leg MMO the
biggest MMO of this generation in my
opinion at least is destiny and destiny
- okay MMO ask we'll call it that it was
a satisfy you
and those games have exclusive content
on ps4 so we're talking about exclusive
games that are coming out in 2018 these
are new games these are exciting games
you've got the Spyro trilogy coming out
later this year okay
it hasn't been a known like you call him
coming bangs up there buzzing Spyro told
you really wants peyote this is just my
this is just my please Matt's vision to
make it happen
shoot shooters like it is the daddy of
console shooters it's made some missteps
I'm not gonna deny that in recent years
but you can't deny the impact that halo
has had and continues to have in the
world of video games they release the
Master Chief collection and sure it had
some problems at launch but it's still
showing that Microsoft and 343 pouring
love and energy into these games and
they want to bring those old games that
so many people loved to modern-day
consoles people might not have a 360 or
an intro or an original Xbox to play it
first-person shooters you got that
sorted third-person Gears of War baby
baby baby I mean jeez I'm for my money I
really really enjoyed it and not only
did it feel mr. oh god I hate that with
like you know it just felt crunchy so
good to play and it looks incredible now
that it's on Xbox one you've got things
like deep rock galactic you have pop G I
mean so not only do they have the big
names but with idea Xbox for example as
well they're also supporting upcoming
shooters I agree that Halo probably was
the granddaddy of console shooters but
the fact is the big boy now on console
in terms of the shooters it's called a
GE and in Call of Duty you get all the
map packs first on ps4 so if you're a
Call of Duty fan if you're a shooter fan
likely it is you're playing Call of Duty
and if you're playing Call of Duty the
best place to play that is on ps4
because not only is that gonna be a work
where all of your friends playing but
also you get those map packs a month
early so you're not gonna be behind the
times that is completely fair but third
party time exclusives is that the only
leg you have to stand on I mean no of
course not you brought in third-person
shooters as well right you brought in
Gears of War fine yeah it gives water
it's a really good series but it's
nothing compared to uncharted and now
you've got the entire uncharted
collection on ps4 tightened up better
than they were on ps3 and look
let me remind you that I'm Charlie the
first time tide was okay it was it was
good I tried to it's one of the best
games ever made on Charlie three I
really really enjoyed uncharted 4 is
absolutely amazing an entire Lost Legacy
was a really good it was like a bonus
uncharted riddle me this do you play on
tide because of the shooting yes I do
yes
those games are great but honestly they
are not good shoes
you play on try it for the story you
play on tired for Nathan Drake and is
wise is wisecracking you play for Chloe
you play for Sully you play for these
big huge action set-pieces that you can
be a part of it's like playing a movie
right that's the whole thing they were
going for they've got it almost right in
for and the Lost Legacy that's the best
it's ever been what to say that coming
out of the gate the greatest shooter I
have on ps4 is uncharted is frankly
ridiculous
why what other like cheers yeah kill
zone this year Bravo Team a VR shoot
have you got any our shooters on xbox
yeah but for people who want to play a
VR shooter you've lost something you you
you want things to go down are you
trying to go down that Avenue they're
all blocks off your work for every road
loose quantity over quality no quality
is what most of us buy Charlie would not
bring up Bravo Team unless you were
absolutely scraping about because I came
by all accounts hang on a minute
you've got you you've come at me with
pub G which is an absolute mess on Xbox
right now it is a mess
have you tried playing on xbox on PC
Kraken great game update yes I have yeah
No all right enough of their
jibber-jabber let us know your thoughts
on who you think won the debate by
voting in the above poll or if you're
over on GameSpot gone by putting your
thoughts in the comment section below
it'll be your votes that decides who
wins so make yourselves heard before we
round out the show we've got the quick
fire round
the plucky pair will now answer a series
of dumb questions written by the rest of
the UK team naturally Oscar and Lucy you
haven't seen any of these so it should
be fun alright let's do it yeah
Berman's before bridge console exclusive
character would you take home to meet
your parents
a lie I mean nah she's just she's well
fit which console is the most
aerodynamic do you alright mate
ps4 ps4 definitely not a Xbox one next
it's a brick X with 1x it's still a
brick it just happens to be a little bit
smaller than the OG brick the question
was not which is lighter which is the
most aerodynamic I'm going to test this
out by getting a ps4 slim I'm throwing
it at my place right if your console was
a fragrance what would it smell like -
smell like like freshly mown when I
think of X but I think like was this
green isn't a rough-and-tumble ps4 would
smell like smoke
would smell like a really manly
aftershave then it would smell like a
really woman via do an impression of
your favorite mascot slash character oh
it was that crash bandicoot ok with you
we used to knock in my control I'll do
whatever then we're one who would win in
a fight between Nathan Drake and the
Steve from minecraft I'm gonna have to
go out on a limb here and say this team
yeah yeah
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll and in the comment section below
and tell us who you think argue their
case better and if you enjoyed this
episode of vs. make sure to hit that
subscribe button as we'll have new
episodes the show every Wednesday
afternoon at 4 p.m. Pt thank you so much
for watching and we'll see you in
[Music]